that's not the plan
who would for you like would there be
any sort of like
dream collaboration that you are working
on or want to see happen soon within re
within reason you know everybody wants
to work with Andre 3000 and you know
see I knew it by the way he's got a new
album on the way Killer Mike said that I
was just saying I should on the way here
yeah
by the way crazy yeah incredible you
gotta listen to the whole thing but yeah
he's incredible dream collaboration
Andre
yeah I mean I I see it happening for
sure um and Kendrick as well I see that
for sure coming through uh as far as
like production though because we're
we're a production dude we just finished
executive producing rhapsody's new album
oh yes and she's on uh she's on this
album or the last album she's on this
one yeah two features shout out to
Rhapsody oh she's one of them ones
[__] crazy and you guys worked with
The Alchemist yeah so what was that did
you he handle the full production on
that one and you just kind of did your
thing out he sent he sent the record
um I had sent him a joint
and I was like yo like I want to do a
switch up right here and I want your
beat to come in and I sent it to him
he's like yo the [__] that you have
there is crazy are you sure you wanna I
was like bro to work with you would be
what we need right so um he sent a bunch
of stuff back
and he's very hard to get in touch with
it so um oh I know I didn't hear from
him for a while so we just threw some
stuff over it and um sent it back to him
and he was [__] with it through a
couple more things and then yeah did you
shred over at some Alchemist
that was actually the song that I got to
shred over here crazy yeah yeah
it's them talking like having this like
psychedelic sexual conversation and
you're shredding the background yeah oh
it's disgusting would you consider I
feel like your music is very solid music
to shroom to
sure is that fair absolutely
shroom it's like like I feel like I'm
like a PR like I I I do enjoy mushrooms
heavily yeah yeah and I feel like when I
hear you guys are [__] I'm like man
there's some [__] I can listen to like
looking at the stars just [__] yeah
tripping trying to make it take you out
there it's like cinematic as possible so
it's like you guys are like the [__]
Soulful Tame Impala because I didn't
know Tame Impala was one dude so it's
kind of the opposite right it's kind of
like I always thought Tame Impala was
like 30 [__] when I found out
it was one guy my whole world melted
yeah that was nuts when I found out too
I was like this guy's a maniac [__] it's
crazy to him man so uh you said Andre
what you know what's crazy is like has
anybody from dreamville reached out to
you guys because I feel like you guys
are definitely like yeah you guys should
do dreamville Fest or something
I think we yeah they yeah I don't know
what happened I wanted to do that they
hit us up for some [__] I don't think I
went through somebody from dreamville
did reach out
um I got this weird superstition about
signing to artists I'm not even talking
about that I just mean like to work or
to collaborate I would love to and those
are the that's what I'm saying like
those are the kind of toppings like that
we would [__] like we would love to
have we just I don't know it just feels
like it
at this point I mean earth king yeah
yeah they they typed in with us but I've
been wanting to call to see us for a
minute I don't know jid's incredible you
guys work with mariba right yeah mariba
is a part of uh spillage village with
j.i.d and black and everybody so yeah
Marie was incredible [__] bro she's such
a good writer yeah she's been crazy on
ghost ride yeah she went nuts on that um
shout out to mariva um I was gonna say
uh there is I agree with you on your uh
point about not signing to an artist but
if there was an artist assigned to it I
feel like it'd be cool yeah because I
feel like Cole's done such a good job of
like high art Integrity artists yeah and
like he's so out the way that like when
you think of dreamville like you think
of cold but like now I mean dude jid is
a [__] massive Ari Linux is [__]
massive like you know like and I just
feel like he's done such a good job of
like him and uh Eve over there have done
such a good job of building like
high high level roster of talent that
isn't necessarily I'm signing you
because you got a [__] hot record you
know I'm signing you because I believe
in you yeah he's so different though J
Cole like I I he's a he's an anomaly
like for sure
he's part owner of the Charlotte Hornets
now that's right yeah
Jordan sold the Hornets to a group that
includes J Cole it's [__] incredible
three billion or something crazy like
that
crazy upward Mobility man that's that's
generational values building